If you focus solely on your career, you can end it.
And I would say that a minority of men prefer
that strategy, work is all they do, 70 or 80 hours a week. They totally go for their career.
They bet everything on the small chance to excel in a limited domain.
But that is hard for them. They have no life and it is difficult for them to have a family.
They do not know how to enjoy their free time, they develop very unilaterally. Maybe that is
One-sidedness is the price that you have to pay
to excel. Because if you want to be a brilliant mathematician, for example
or a scientist, then you are
always at work in your laboratory, 70 to 80 hours a week.
You are intelligent, committed and one-sided.
And that's how you beat your competitors, that's the only way.
But the problem is that you have no life. If you really love science, and if you like that
If you are focused, then first of all you are rare, and secondly: it will cost you, but just what you want.
But it is risky to do, you give up a lot for it.
It is not a healthy life, because then you have to divide your attention more
so that you can have a family and activities other than work that are meaningful and meaningful.
You have a circle of friends.
These three, four things alone are enough to keep you on track.
If there is a collapse,
then you have not lost everything.
The price you pay for this is that the more you want to keep these things in balance, the less likely you are
will excel in one of them, but if you consider your life as a whole
then this could be a winning strategy. Carl Jung said something that really appeals to me.
He thought that men were striving for perfection, and women for "wholeness," in which they differ.
There is something else at the top of their value hierarchy.
Perfection would be
to bet on one thing and strive for radical success, not that all men do, we are now talking about the extremes.
The "wholeness" idea is something else.
Or you want one thing in your life that is 150%,
or you want five that are each 80%.
Well,
there is much more wealth in a life in which five aspects are 80% each
but none achieves the 150%.
I really believe that because I have seen men and women go through their careers for a long time,
and what i have seen,
although there are several reasons for this,
but something I have seen is that women are leaving their one-sided careers after their 30th birthday.
They don't want that anymore. They no longer feel like investing those 80 hours that would be needed
to be at the forefront of their field.
The reason they do that is that they decide it's not worth it, and no wonder.
You have to ask yourself how it could be worth it. If you want to be an excellent scientist
That is fine in itself to want and to do, if you really really want it. Because then you have to do that too.
Because you have to compete with other people who are smart
and work hard.
If you want to get to the top, you have to be the smartest and work the hardest, and that means hard work
make long days. You must of course be diligent, but ultimately
It is also a matter of addition if I am smart and I work hard for 70 hours a week
and you for 30 hours, I will be so far ahead of you within two years that you will never catch up with me again.
So.
And I think that part of the reason why women are more oriented
or actually I think there are two reasons.
Firstly: because of a higher socio-economic status, women are not considered more attractive as potential partners,
and men do. Secondly, women have less time available.
Because guys can say: well, I will have children later, and they can keep going until they are 80.
While that is for women: absolutely not, you have to
have arranged your affairs when you are 40, actually before, 35.
But certainly before you turn 40, because otherwise you will miss the boat and that is terrible, the most unfortunate people out there ...
No,
No.
A common way to extreme unhappiness is to want children and not to have them.
I don't recommend it to anyone.
You know that among people in their thirties, one in every three couples has fertility problems. That means
that you are not pregnant after a year of trying. One in three.
So you better think about that, because people become very unhappy if they want children and it doesn't work.
Then you will be in the medical mill for ten years.